intro
hey leute und will kommt zum einen
beitrag zur messe gamescom 2012
letztes wochenende in köln bzw köln
deutsch bzw koelnmesse keine ahnung wie
das genau dieser bezirk dieses motto da
heißt keine ahnung
jedenfalls war die halter und ich war
dazu besucher mit dmc und ein paar
anderen leuten und wir sind dann da halt
über ein video day geschlendert über die
messe nachher noch geschlüpft und haben
dann nachher noch bei michaels was
gegessen sind mit dem zug zurück und so
weiter und so fort jedenfalls habe ich
auf der messe echt eine menge gefilmt
und ich wollte doch eigentlich dazu was
reden und kommentieren und leute
interviewen allerdings hatte ich
verteilt mir vorher noch ein passendes
micro für die kamera zu kaufen
und deswegen konnte ich dann hatte ich
damit erkennen was aufgenommen aber da
war immer in den hallen seinen grund
dezibel pegel von so 10 milliarden plus
irgendwas was ich jedenfalls konnte man
meine stimme gar nicht hören und das war
alles nur total kratzig dann direkt
davor gehen musste deswegen werde ich
jetzt einfach ein paar bilder zeigen und
videos und da ein bisschen chillige
musik hinterlegen gezeigt habe ich mich
in den videos nicht wenn ihr die
kommentierte videos haben wollten guckt
euch das video von denen ca das ist auf
seinem kanal und timo und interview
antworten verlinkt keine ahnung wie wir
das machen da interviewt der ein paar
leute ist auf jeden fall ganz
interessant auf jeden fall vorbeigucken
und zeigen möchte ich mich zurzeit noch
nicht weil es für meine jetzigen
geplanten projekte erst mal nicht in
frage steht vielleicht irgendwann werde
ich mich mal zeigen wer weiß wer weiß
wer weiß
aber zurzeit erst mal nicht deswegen
meckert bitte nicht darum
und übrigens dank an 40.000 abonnenten
sieht das mal so als kleines special
sage ich mal so aus dem echten leben
lahm
irgendwann kommt dann bei 50.000 mit ihr
alle nicht gerechnet hätte da ja egal
das soll mal so als kleine vorbereitung
und viel spaß bei dem video ich würde
mich freuen und wir sehen uns
nächste mal
an
auch um
ein
mit sich
oktober aus
dennis seinen lappen alter ohne scheiß
worden
day
ist
archiv
ja